reden wir darüber was dieser zweite
corona herbst für deutschland bedeutet
in berlin bin ich verbunden mit dem co
vorsitzenden der afd meteogroup aller
größe in die hauptstadt wenn wir das
richtig gelesen haben beginnen wir bei
ihnen persönlich
dann waren sie kürzlich teil der vierten
welle was hat das mit ihnen gemacht ja
ich war infiziert ich hatte leichte
symptome und ich bin seit letzter woche
wieder genesen und schauen sie dann nach
ihrer genesung auf die korona pandemie
ja was wir jetzt erleben wir
hauptsächlich auch über die
entscheidungen der bundesregierung aber
auch zum beispiel der landesregierung in
sachsen ja voraussagen ist dass hier
wieder mit einer panik begonnen wird
dass man wieder um sich schlägt mit
ausgrenzung vor allen dingen von
personen gruppen die nicht geimpft sind
dass man die gesellschaft weiter spalten
will und das ist das was wir kritisieren
dass man aus den fehlern auch nicht
gelernt hat dass man sogar in dieser
zeit im letzten jahr krankenhausbetten
abgebaut hat weiterhin und sogar
krankenhäuser wie in sachsen geschlossen
hat also dass man hier auch
personalmäßig nicht aufgestockt hat weil
das ist ja das hauptproblem nicht bloß
die bettenanzahl der intensivbetten
wurde reduziert sondern als auch
personal nicht ausreichend vorhanden ist
oder fragten sich wo ist eigentlich die
offensive was neues personal grabpflege
und auch im krankenhaus bereich angeht
wo ist das eigentlich hin gegangen warum
ist aber nicht passiert das ist das
absolute versagen der bundesregierung
und auch der landesregierung ja nun
haben wir ein wechsel in der
bundesregierung und das wird auch das
neue punkte geben tatsächlich wird auch
der neue deutsche bundestag der sich ja
konstruiert hat in dem fall jetzt dann
ohne ihre persönliche anwesenheit wird
jetzt erst in kürze nächster woche
beraten über die fortsetzung der
epidemischen lage das ist ja so nicht
vorgesehen durch die künftigen ampel
koalitionäre aber trotzdem braucht es
eine antwort auf diese vierte welle das
dem würden sie zustimmen hier die
antwort könnte man da hingehen gehen
dass man sagt gerade was krankenhäuser
was aber auch altenheime angeht dass man
wieder mit testen beginnt und auch
weiter dieses testen aus weiter das ist
natürlich durchaus wichtig und dass vor
allem diese tests auch kostenlos
angeboten wird dass man hier nicht die
soziale spaltung auch in diesem bereich
weiter vorantreibt das ist denke ich mal
wichtig und natürlich auch immerhin den
fokus auf die eigenverantwortung der
bevölkerung lenkt die bevölkerung ist
sensibilisiert aber jetzt zum beispiel
auf zweig umzuschwenken viele haben sich
wie wir es in bericht ja gerade gesehen
haben auch eingerichtet viele
unternehmen haben sich darauf
eingerichtet auch wirtshäuser die
gastronomie die hotellerie jetzt auf
zweig umzuschwenken ist wirklich
katastrophal man bringt wieder panik
hinein und verunsichert die bevölkerung
und nochmal man spaltet die gesellschaft
in ungünstigen genesene aber wir wissen
ja mittlerweile dass auch die impfung
eben durchaus nicht überall wirkt und
das ist mittlerweile eine große anzahl
von 30 40 durch brücken auch gibt
apropos renten sie selber hatten diese
frage bisher unbeantwortet lassen das
heißt ein impfstoff durchbruch war das
bei ihnen nicht ich lasse die frage auch
weiterhin unbeantwortet weil das wie
gesagt meine private entscheidung ist ob
ich mich impfen lasse oder ob ich mich
auch impfen lassen werde und das sollte
auch jeder für sich entscheiden und es
beantworte ich auch nicht der kubaner in
ihrem heimatbundesland weise gerade so
ein bisschen auf die 2g und 3g abgehoben
haben gibt es ja morgen dann eine
entscheidung des sächsischen kabinetts
darüber dass man mutmaßlich zweig zum
standard machen will zumindest für
bestimmte bereiche im grunde genommen
kann es ja nicht sein dass eine
landesregierung einfach nichts tut also
etwas tun ist doch besser als ganzes tun
ja aber mit blick auf maß und vor allem
nicht mit panik was hier betrieben wird
ist panik und fand es ist rechtswidrig
die 2g regeln und das sagen viele
juristen ist rechtswidrig verstoß gegen
das grundgesetz weil man hier
personengruppen rohstoffen juristisch
angreifen kann man ja dann einfach
austesten will man landet
tatsächlich gibt es bereiche wo sensibel
wird sie haben gerade die pflegeheime
angesprochen das ist ein wichtiger punkt
wir haben in mehreren bundesländern
schleswig-holstein aber auch brandenburg
massive todesfälle gehabt und dann auch
tatsächlich noch einmal die belege durch
die amtsärzte das zum teil nur 50
prozent der mitarbeiter dort geimpft
werden da wäre doch eine ängstlich dann
angemessen also doch mal was sagt das
muss man aus hessen auch juristisch also
ich halte das grundgesetz nicht für
austauschbar
auf der juristischen ebene also das
grundgesetz gilt für alle und auch die
freiheit und grundrechte gelten für alle
so was kann man nicht austesten sowas
muss man juristisch vor einer
entscheidung treffen und auch abwägen
und natürlich müssen die wohlhabenden
gruppen geschützt wenn krankenhäuser
geschützt werden aber ich halte auch
hier nichts von einer impfpflicht noch
mal impfen ist die eigenverantwortung
eines jeden bürgers und wer sich impfen
lassen möchte wer sich dadurch einen
schutz verspricht er soll das gern tun
aber eine pflicht halte ich für
grundsätzlich schwierig und auch für
grundgesetzlich für unverantwortlich das
heißt wir setzen auf die vernünftige des
einzelnen und setzen auch darauf nur
dass wir sie dann nochmal präzise
verstehen an der stelle sie haben das
testen angesprochen vor allen dingen das
kostenlose testen beziehen sie das jetzt
ausdrücklich auf die pflegeheime oder
soll dass wir alle wieder kostenfrei
sein ziemliche faktoren klar ja gut dass
im fluss auch ein kostenfaktor also ich
halte die die tief die testpflicht oder
beziehungsweise das testen im pflege und
altenheim euren krankenhäusern für
durchaus angebracht das ist durchaus ein
probates mittel aber nochmal auch hier
der test für alle wenn wir sehen ja dass
mittlerweile auch geimpfte ein crooner
infizieren sie können auch an krone
erkranken aber auch crooner weiter
verbreiten können also müssen auch diese
theoretisch bei diesen bilderrahmen
gruppen aber auch bei krankenhäusern
altenpflegeheimen auch dort eine
testpflicht unterliegen ja herr grugger
noch mal letzter punkt für uns beide
nächste woche deutscher bundestag
plenarsitzung die fdp hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen die 3g regel im plenum
fortsetzen zu wollen würde das bedeutet
sozusagen teile der fdp fraktion dann
wieder auf den besuchertribünen ja wir
werden definitiv gegen diese 3g regel
stimmen im bundestag nächste woche dann
vielen dank für dieses gespräch diene
copala war das gerade genesen von corona
der co-vorsitzende der afg danke nach
berlin sehr gerne